[Music]
so
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [__]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[__] em
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
today
we got some video that we missed
yesterday because i'm so [__] pissed
off
about the video from involved
footage from evoli not just the footage
from evaldi but also
thinking back to the footage of greg
abbott lying to the american people and
the families in uvalde
about actually what happened and what he
knew and that happened inside that
school
so we we took a lot of time yesterday on
that so i want to get to
the josh hawley video i can't not show
this video
i have some other uh video i want to
show about marjorie taylor green and
it's actually just like a voicemail
i'm actually i don't know i have doubts
about it actually
um
i have doubts about it
my mic is really low can you can you
guys hear me out there everyone say that
you can hear me or you can't hear me
i believe
that my mic is good it should be good
it should be good
so
we have a lot of turn your mic up a bit
tony is what they're saying
oh let's see
it might need some adjusting here
there how's that how's that i turned it
up just a bit
turned it up just a bit
i'll be louder trust me i'm gonna be
loud
we're gonna be loud here today loud and
proud as we are
as always here on the tony michaels
podcast every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific
on youtube twitter twitch and also
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page and boy do you guys come
over from the facebook page but don't
forget if you're on the facebook page to
subscribe to the youtube channel you
don't want to miss anything over on the
youtube channel you don't want to miss
anything over there
so we're a week out from the next
january 6 select committee hearing
a week out we're not sure exactly what
time it's going to be the exact time
that's why we haven't put a link out yet
i want to let everyone know that it
seems as if
that the january 6 select committee has
confirmed it is thursday next week in
prime time
they just haven't nailed down a time
so because we don't have a time we don't
want to create confusion by releasing a
link for a certain time and people think
it's that time and the committee changes
the time
and then we have to change the link and
it just creates confusion they kind of
created confusion last this week now for
tuesday's hearing when they changed
the time at the last minute that you
know the couple days before so we want
to try to have as less amount of
confusion as we possibly can so
bear with us as we
um try to figure out exactly what time
if they'll confirm a time for us so that
we can put out a link to you but here's
what you can do here's what you can do
go ahead and subscribe to our youtube
channel again the tony michaels podcast
right here on youtube if you're on
facebook the link it's a very at the
very top of the page you can also follow
us on uh twitch um as well
but the best place to follow us is at
tonymichaelspod
and at the tony michaels and i am gabe
sanchez if you're on twitter we will be
spreading around the link once we get
that link
for next week's hearing
now why am i talking about the hearing
today
well ashley babbitt
is trending because her husband says
that she was trying to stop the
insurrection which is [__] she was
the insurrection she was the exact type
of [__] stupid-ass [__]
queuing on her that donald trump knew
that he could turn
into a violent insurrectionist in the
name of trump and trumpism he knew that
he knew these q and honors would do what
ashley babbitt did which was go to the
capitol and try to actually enter into
not only a restricted area but a lot
restricted area that is guarded because
it is a speaker's lobby
speaker of the house and other
politicians are inside in leadership or
inside not just and it's not just
democrats you know that that's one thing
they want to make it into
when the republicans have the house
the republican speaker of the house is
in that lobby so it's not nancy pelosi's
lobby
it is the speaker's lobby it is the
house it is our
capital those are our elected officials
that is our government
and they are afforded the protection
away from violent insurrectionists
especially in a locked and restricted
area
where they're trying to operate our
government
so
ashley babbitt
as much as she's a bonehead and believed
trump's lies she did not [__]
she didn't it's not no no
no
she did not try to stop the insurrection
she was the insurrection okay
there's video evidence of this
right before
she gets shot because she
was trying to enter a restricted locked
area
as the tactical team was moving in
this is what happened there's video
evidence of it it's not complicated it's
not hard to understand it's not rocket
surgery
we have evidence
video evidence clear video evidence that
ashley babbitt was the insurrection
she wasn't trying to stop it you [__]
bonehead and ashley babbitt's husband
can [__] all the way off all the way
[__] him
trying to rewrite history and make
ashley babbin into some kind of [__]
hero she's not a hero
those insurrectionists weren't heroes
they were traitors to our country and
our government and our vote
the stop the steel [__] and all this
stuff they keep clamoring on about with
the with [__] the cheeto dust monster
talking about the wisconsin supreme
court
peter navarro christina bob that [__]
scumbag talking about how they're gonna
get state legislators to give news
electors and send it to congress and
some dumb ass [__] this is all coup it's
all coup attempts it's all against our
constitution there's nothing in those
documents that give the right to any of
these people to do what they say they're
doing
they're traitors
they are [__] traitors
it is a cheeto dust
confederacy
that's part of the roe v wade decision
is to create a cheeto dust confederacy
we see the [__] attorney general of
indiana today more concerned
more concerned about how a little girl
who was [__] raped
and impregnated and couldn't receive an
abortion because she was [__] raped
in ohio crossing a border she's more
worried about prosecuting her
and they're worried about the
immigration status of the man who raped
her he's a [__] rapist charge him who
gives a [__] who he is or what he is or
where he came from what his name is he's
a [__] rapist
charge him but they're more concerned oh
the indiana attorney general is going to
go to every link necessary to make sure
to charge the person that brought this
little girl to indiana to make sure she
didn't carry
that in sexual rapist
baby to term a little girl
not a not not a young woman a little
girl 10 years old you [__] scumbags
in indiana you republican scumbags that
support this attorney general [__] you
all the way [__] you all the way off
ashley babbitt susman and you
they're traitors
it's what they are it's a cheeto dust
confederacy
it's what they want
i talked about it yesterday greg abbott
signed that bill into law that allowed
that young man to go into the school in
uvalde and murder those children greg
abbott did that it's on his hands
and we can't let up we have to
politicize every single one of these
issues everyone's like oh don't
politicize it tony [__] that [__]
[__] it
you want you want to [__] get rid of
these [__] fascists you want them to
crawl back underneath their [__]
rocks where they belong
well let's play ball
let's do this let's play politics baby
let's do that [__] let's politicize the
ever loving [__] out of this
let's do that yeah yo
they'll they'll say all kinds of [__]
about me i don't care i don't give a
[__] you think the [__] guy cares
what the hell they say about me i don't
give a [__]
[__] them
let's politicize the [__] out of this
so come here every single weekday monday
through friday for two full hours
and you'll learn how to politicize the
ever loving [__]
out of this [__]
take it out into your communities engage
in the ballot like i've been talking
about have that strategic outrage be
pissed
make sure you're engaging in your ballot
not just marking your ballot but
engaging in it that's what democracy is
we have to do democracy we have to
[__] do the [__]
to save it
you can't just sit around and hope
everyone goes and votes you have to
engage you have to get people engaged
you have to get them to want to vote
best way to get someone to vote is to
vote against something by god there's
nothing better than people being
motivated to go vote against something
trust me
it's politics
now you may say ah you're out of your
mind you're crazy
let's hold hands and do kumbaya no we're
way past that [__] point a playing
kumbaya with any kind of [__]
nincompoop nazis like ashley babbitt
[__] that [__]
you want a bunch of ashley babbitt's
running your [__] your your county
running your [__] school board and
your state
dictating
who and what and can and where in your
state you want these people going up to
washington ashley babbitt's
to go up to what is have you seen her
[__] rants she's out of her [__]
mind
was out of her [__] mind
sorry i got the wrong tense there i
don't want to offend anybody
actually i do
i do get offended get offended you right
wingers get offended you queueing honors
give a [__]
we need to offend these people it's
enough of this [__] poop nazi [__]
this fascism this [__] cheeto dust
confederacy it's time for us to fight
back
it's [__] about gas prices and the
economy and the media buying into it i
talked about it yesterday these
[__]
buying into this [__]
listen wages are up 17
because of inflation
because people have mobility and jobs
because there's
demand don't let the fed gas light you
don't let don't let anyone gaslight you
especially the [__] media they are
derelict in their duty here they are not
reporting the [__] facts
just because they report what the gas
prices are for three four [__] months
about how they're going up that not a
goddamn word about them [__] tumbling
down
about how they were wrong they were
[__] wrong
they're wrong about inflation too yes
inflation hurts anytime the economy
changes it always always hurts the
middle and lower class in this country
always and the trouble that we have
right now is we've had two changes in
the last two years
one because of the pandemic and the
response from [__] captain [__]
and then once we get a reasonable
[__] in office
to actually have a response to the
pandemic in the economy the economy
changes
so yeah it's a it's difficult it's a
difficult economic time
but it doesn't mean the economy's bad
that's all a bunch of horse [__]
they're trying to sell you so the
fascists get in office so they can take
your [__] economy away from you and
i'm talking about your personal economy
they want to destroy the economy jim
jordan can't wait can't wait for the
economy to be destroyed to blame it on
joe biden so he can get reelected to
really [__] with the economy
[__] these [__]
fight back this nonsense is [__] our
unemployment rate is damn near three and
a half percent which is almost nothing
in the history of our country wages are
up people have job mobility the only
places that have now hiring signs
that are begging for [__] labor
are the ones who aren't paying what the
labor's worth that's why no one's
[__] working there
so you can be damn rest assured if you
go to some some business establishment
and they only got one [__]
working in there and can't serve the
customers it's because the people who
own that son of a [__] aren't trading
enough money for the labor
i wish people would understand that in
this economy we've been so [__]
brainwashed by the goddamn media about
how [__] free markets work
and brainwashed by the goddamn gqp the
fascist as if
as if the corporation and the company
you work for is doing you a favor by
paying you for your labor [__] that [__]
get the [__] out of here with that
they are not doing you a favor you are
doing them a favor you are providing
them your labor for their production for
their profits and it's a trade
you are trading your labor
for money and benefits that is the
[__] case
look most people in this country don't
have a lot of [__] money in capital
to trade they don't the best capital you
have is your [__] labor most of the
time
that's what most americans trade for
money is their [__] labor
they're not doing you the privilege of
giving you a job [__] that [__] and i
think americans during the pandemic
realize this as corporations would [__]
all over them
[__] all over them i think people
realize that yeah i can go get a better
job somewhere else [__] this guy
[__] this company
treat me like i'm a piece of [__]
meat
like i owe them a favor [__] that [__]
they owe me a favor
i'm the one giving my labor
i'm the one producing the profit for
them
yeah they hold the capital they hold the
money which that's why they own the
company
but their company would be [__] without
us we know that now
and the pandemic just made that very
apparent and obvious
and that's why we have the mobility and
the demand
this idea that the economy is bad is a
bunch of [__] it's just a bunch of
nonsense
do the [__] math the demand demand is
what drives the economy that's what
drives it that's it there's no
supply-side economics the republicans
tried to sell us that [__] and they're
still trying to sell us that [__] and
you should know if republicans are
trying to sell you something it's a
[__] lie
been a lie always was a lie always will
be a lie
supply-side economics are bone-headed
and that's not how it [__] works at
all not even close
it's demand that drives the economy just
tick back if you can remember 2008 when
everyone stopped spending money
because it dried up
there was no demand because no one was
spending money
think about this for a second think
about this for a second
their ideas to draw us into a recession
with higher interest rates
that's the idea
to try to to
to placate to the media to try to
placate to the [__] fascist and the
more you believe it and the more you
[__] say [__] like that
you pro-democracy people out there who
placate into this bad economy inflation
[__] you're only causing and helping the
problem
of them raising interest rates on us the
american people us
the people with the money aren't going
to pay the [__] interest rates they
have the money
the people who are gonna pay the money
on the interest rates are the people
trading their labor because they're not
you're not trading money to get money
you're trading your labor
that's how you live that's how you
survive that's how you make it in this
free market that we created that the
republicans want to tear down they want
to make it autocracy they want to make
it a fascist state
which is not free market
but they're trying to convince you that
inflation is worse
than high interest rates and it's not
that's all [__]
you're gonna spend more money if you are
a person who is trading your labor for
money you have debt a car a house all
these things you're gonna pay more money
with higher interest rates than you are
with inflation
it's really bone-headed [__] type [__]
and the media's not saying it
and you definitely aren't going to see
republicans tell you the [__] truth
i'm going to tell you the [__] truth
jesus christ the truth is their [__]
enemy
we see that with the january 6 select
committee over and over and over time
and time every time we have one geez
there's so many goddamn pieces of truth
that are their [__] enemy you can't
even keep track of them
so be pro-democracy be pro-america
that's actual patriotism to believe in
your [__] country to believe in your
fellow countrymen
that they can make the right decisions
based on what how they want to trade
their [__] labor
that's why labor unions are so goddamn
important to make sure that these
[__] corporations understand that
you're not doing us a favor we're doing
you a favor
you're getting our labor at a discount
frankly
you pieces of [__] [__] gouging the
[__] out of us on the ass end of it too
that's where a bunch of them this
inflation is coming from and now
if you think corporations are going to
lower your prices as interest rates go
up you are a [__] bonehead
until demand starts to drop they're not
going to lower their prices why would
they
as long as you're still spending money
which americans are which you should be
you should spend your money the way you
want
you work hard for it you've gotten
raises you've moved jobs to get a better
pay
and yes some americans are still hurting
because all these things rather it's
inflation the interest rates going up
recession
the economy always affects the folks
that are trading labor
the most
because they get the least amount of
money for their labor whereas someone
with capital with money gets a hell of a
lot more
money for their capital
we gotta pluck our head out of our asses
here it's enough of this fascist ass
[__] this [__] talking lines from
the right wing in the far right [__]
them
we do not have to placate into their
nonsense rather the media parrots it or
not which they are parodying it
squawk squawk squawk about how the
inflation bad inflation bad well what
about inflation of wages [__]
what about that that doesn't sound bad
to me at all
what about inflation on that price of
your uh pricey the the actual assets
that you own if you're a homeowner out
there you've gained a lot of [__]
capital in the last two years because of
inflation
if you're not a homeowner
your labor has been inflated
this is nonsense and we need to stop
playing into their [__] hands here we
gotta stop we gotta stop being on
opposite teams when we're on the same
[__] team we're on team of
democracy here
until we decide that we're going to
fight for one [__] goal which is to
make sure our goddamn democracy stands
so that we can fight out these [__]
issues that we want to fight out
what should the minimum wage be
what kind of health care system should
we have
should children start school at three
instead of five
we don't want people to [__] go broke
because of a medical bill or a goddamn
college education to advance their
career and to do good by america and
production and the way of life here in
our country and our democracy
these are the ideas we should be we
should be fighting about but we can't
fight those ideas with fascists we can't
we can't set policy with on those issues
with them in control are you [__] out
of your mind
so pluck your head out of your ass and
understand
understand that the democracy is the
thing that gets you what you want and it
isn't always gonna deliver everything
you want
there's two things at play here and i
keep talking about them i keep saying
this i'm going to beat it into every
brain that i can
there is
government which is policy that's the
line items and all the [__] that we want
to do to make this country better codify
roe v wade make sure women
jesus christ we should go back and just
do the era for crying out loud
the equal rights amendment
making sure
to to extend voting rights
not take them away make sure everyone
who is eligible to vote can and has an
easy way to vote rather that be early
dropping a ballot in a ballot box by
mail however we can do it to make it
easy for someone to participate and
engage in their democracy we should be
doing that
to make sure that kids start their
education at three instead of five
and their education doesn't [__]
hinder them after they leave high school
for their entire [__] lives and leave
them in debt
to the [__] government
make sure that you don't go broke
because of a medical bill
but it's up to you it's up to you the
pro-democracy voters out there the
pro-democracy coalition
because granted it is a coalition folks
we are the most diverse coalition and
not just by gender not just not just by
race not just by religion but by
beliefs yes the the pro-democracy
rebel
coalition has democratic socialist in it
it has liberals in it
it has progressives in it
it has people who advocate for women's
rights who advocate for lgbtq rights who
advocate for voting rights
we have independents we have moderates
we're not going to agree on a lot of
things
so let's let's do the thing that we can
all agree on that us the pro-democracy
people are the ones who should be in
charge of policy in this country because
we are the only ones that [__] are
level-headed and are even adhered to any
kind of reality
to bring this country
forward to make sure we don't topple
into in a fascist state
and we cannot negotiate with a bunch of
nincompoop nazis we can't do it [__]
them
[__] them [__] [__] em [__] em [__] em
[__] em
[__] the gqp that's your that's your
[__] campaign strategy [__] em
they're not gonna work for you
they're not
and yeah you're not going to agree with
all the candidates that you're going to
have to vote for
but they're but you are going to agree
on one thing and you should
is that we are a democracy at the very
least
but we want pro-democracy policy in
place
and we want it now we don't want to wait
and the only way to do that is to every
single election is the next biggest
election folks that's how democracy is
if you're pro-democracy and you're
sitting there thinking oh well tony
every single election is the biggest
election and that's all it is just get
reel that's democracy
what do you think elections are they're
[__] democracy and we always have one
every two years sometimes every year
depending on which state you live in
we have key elections because that is
democracy that's what it is you should
be excited about voting i wish we could
vote every [__] six months
every six months we should be voting
hell every three months that's democracy
that's the beautiful part of it
is to not just vote but to engage in it
that's what we have to do that's where
we have to get to in this pro-democracy
coalition we have to be excited about
the next big election
of how we can change
and right now
the biggest thing that we can change
is to make sure more pro-democracy
candidates
represent us not just in the federal
government
we got it we got to make sure they
represent us in the senate and the house
we have to make sure of that but these
governors races are crucially important
in texas
bet o'rourke is the pro-democracy
candidate
he is he's the pro-democracy candidate
you may not agree with beto on every
single issue that's okay
but the key thing is is that beto
believes in democracy he believes in it
and that's the key
that's the key
in georgia
brian kemp hates democracy so much so
that he wants to take democracy away
from people and take their vote away
from them
stacy abrams wants democracy she wants
the voice of the people to be heard
forget about all the other issues that
is the one that is the most important in
our time
the
most
important
so engage in your democracy
participate
do that thing we call democracy and be
excited about it
be excited that this is the this is the
most important election of our lifetime
that's right be excited
because you have the ability
to make this a historic election
for democracy
we see the polls moving
in ohio and pennsylvania in those key
senate races
you turn those seats and we keep the
democratic seats that are at stake in
georgia and arizona and some of these
other key states
you just give two just two
joe mansion and kirsten cinema are
irrelevant
that's right they're irrelevant
we can carve out
exceptions to the filibuster we may not
be able to tear it apart yet but we can
carve out exceptions
to do the bare minimum jesus christ
of democracy you know voting rights
codifying [__] women's bodily
autonomy for crying out loud
but it's up to you you are the one so
stop buying into this [__] [__]
about
these republicans trying to convince
america that our country sucks our
country does not suck our country is not
bad
yes we we have a lot of bad history and
we've done a lot of bad things because
we've let [__] right wingers and
quasi right wingers be in power
but that's because we did not engage and
participate in our democracy so today is
the day now now is the time to
participate do what you can do i yell
and scream into my microphone every
single day that's what i'm good at
that's what i do
you could
give some money to a campaign
fill out some postcards make some phone
calls text message find those campaigns
that you want
but be pro-democracy and show that
you're pro-democracy
we're gonna get into the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends in the [__] list
roundup when we come back from this
break stick around don't go anywhere
we will be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual pardon is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us thanks for
sticking around through the
michaels break
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific
every single weekday two hours a day we
are a week away from the hearing the
next hearing folks and it's supposed to
be the the uh final hearing in this
series
some of the word that we're getting from
dc and some of the insiders into the
january 6th select hearings are saying
that this is a series of hearings that
they possibly after their august break
will come back and do another series
depending on the evidence that they
collect and boy are they still
collecting evidence we watched as liz
cheney burned down donald trump's house
when she called him out for committing
witness tampering a federal felony
at the last hearing where they're trying
to tamper with witnesses which is that
par for the course for trump this is
[__] that he does and [__] that he knows
the [__] that he's gonna continue to do
he's not gonna stop
witness tampering it's not gonna stop
and i actually believe that
liz cheney was not only putting him on
check and putting him on blast
but she was asking other people who had
been
tampered with to go report it like hey
it's a crime tamper with witnesses you
want a way to exalt yourself away from
this [__] fool here's the chance
here's your chance to report a federal
crime where he tampered with you
i i believe that it
do you think donald trump
just crimed once
you think that's the only witness he
tampered with jesus christ we've seen
some text messages
that was trying to tamper with cassidy
hutchinson for [__] sake
that seemed to be tampering for mark
meadows
now regardless the whether mark meadows
directed that or donald trump i think
we're gonna have the evidence and that's
the other [__] things these right
wingers saying oh he pocket dialed he
pocket dialed you can pocket dial
someone oh yeah yeah okay what's the
[__] number one what's the [__]
chances
that donald trump
would pocket dial a witness
that is about to give evidence against
him that he committed crimes come on
number one number two we can prove this
stuff you can prove it you got time
stamp of the phone call you gotta
you could probably zoom in on a certain
area where the phone call was [__]
made from from pinging towers
the other thing too is it's a [__]
federal crime and they take the doj
takes witness tampering more seriously
than
almost anything but [__] murder
i mean they do not like when you [__]
tamper with their witnesses it pisses
them the [__]
off pisses them off
that's why that's why they do not give
two [__]
uh well here's an example remember jared
kushner's dad went to federal prison the
guy went to federal prison because he
was tampering with witnesses
he probably would have won that case
possibly who knows
but he went to prison because he was
tampering with witnesses that was easy
again
slam dunk easy
and if you don't believe
that donald trump is sitting around
eating mcdonald's outside and at his
golf club while he's [__] trying to
call
witnesses and tamper with them give me a
[__] break of course he was there's
cameras all over the place
in those places and when you have a
crime uh the doj can subpoena just about
any evidence they want with a crime
the federal judge will give a warrant
if you got a time date and stamp and you
know where that phone was
you might just get a video at that
moment someone holding it looking at it
you know maybe trying to make a [__]
phone call not pocket dialing
come on give me a [__] break this
[__] is screwed trump is [__]
here
completely [__] especially
since we know trump just didn't make one
phone call to tamper with a witness [__]
no no [__] way
did he just call one [__] we
watched as those son of a [__]
desperately called time and time and
time again we've already watched the
evidence of rudy giuliani
jenna ellis the white house the [__]
trump himself calling these state
election officials and begging them
begging them to make him king and
dictator without any evidence whatsoever
and you think he just called and
intimidated and tampered with one
witness get the [__] out of here with
that [__]
liz cheney was putting it on blast so
that other people had been tampered with
have an opportunity to get in front of
the committee and the doj to cut a deal
that's where we're at in this
anyone out there who says oh the doj and
the select committee they're not blah
blah blah but [__] get the [__] out
of here with that [__]
they absolutely are cooperating they
absolutely are making a case
they are going to go after these
[__] now i have to agree
if they indict and convict trump
if that happens i'm not sure how they
imprison him he's a former president i i
would agree that's a little difficult
to find a place to imprison him
i i don't know what we've never been
there before right so we don't know what
that is i'll agree with that
but the fact remains he's gonna be
indicted
that is what's gonna happen trust me
just go back to my elon musk prediction
and know that i i have a crystal ball
and part of my crystal ball is my
co-host um he's he's got i don't know
he's got some kind of secret algorithm
over there where he figures out
gabe um
this morning uh it is clear that the the
right wingers are really [__]
terrified because ashley
is trending again because i guess
hunters hunters trending today oh is he
he's hunter's been trending well since
the beginning of the week right even i
think maybe a little bit of the weekend
but as we've led up to this additional
hearing that we had on tuesday it would
be gonna you know look at this footage
and it's like one private citizen two
he didn't try to he didn't try to
overthrow the government and and and
throw a coup
right so like you guys trying to just
what about ism doesn't really apply here
like yeah we can agree that hunter biden
you know
he's not a you know he has a lot of [__]
going on
but he's not making money off the
presidency he's not using nepotism
to gain positions of power and then use
that after the fact like people like
ivanka or jared right like i could i saw
tom cotton saying that uh oh jesus
hunter was the only person or is the
only child to make more money than you
know the president of the father which
is like i could name 640 million reasons
specifically why that's not true for
ivanka and jared and an additional 2
billion if we want to go for a
non-immediate family
uh it's the dumbest [__] ever but
again here's here's the tweet i don't
mean to skip ahead yeah yeah yeah but
he's uh here's tom guy and i i tweeted
directly at him i said you're dumber
than a bag of [__] hammers right
hunter biden maybe the only i'm only
american are you [__] [__] me yeah he
became wealthier since his father became
president jesus christ you [__] get
the [__] out of here with that [__] and
maybe he's projecting here that he knows
the trump family is going to be broker
than a joke here soon i mean that's the
road we're headed down yeah um with with
what we're seeing i mean he's also made
what five five million from the nra and
uh
two million from the nra tom gotten
himself time yeah tom cotton was a big
beneficiary since he's been elected
right i think it's two 2 million from
the nra 5 million from the koch brothers
i believe you know i wonder why his
views are the way they are i wonder if
they're butt and baby weird
it's almost like they're given talking
points i mean you got to give it to
conservatives right they they know
exactly the talking points they have to
make and they'll make them regardless of
the mental gymnastics and pretzel logic
that they have right
uh it is very impressive but also just
shockingly dumb
right well
back to the witness tampering here
because i i want to remind the audience
again
i i wish i had a sign up here behind me
that said something like conspiracy
theories aren't conspiracy theories tony
michaels you know like steve bannon
something like that of course i got my
nuggs not drug sign right right right
it's not my it's not my quote but it's a
good one i mean you could do a quote you
could do like a michael scott wayne
gretzky you know kind of thing where
it's like you're quoting someone else
but it's your quote right well hey
that's a good idea yeah here's the thing
if we're talking about witness tampering
and i believe liz cheney's statement
when she taught when she said about the
the call because newsmax is acting like
donald trump [__] butt dialed this
person or something right get
oh [__] here's the thing you can have
evidence because there's
a voicemail well
that's a good point
i want to i want to i want to point out
something here
there were two individuals just in the
last several weeks during
while the hearings were going on in
evans was be collected especially after
cassidy hutchinson
testified and it was very well known to
the to the uh january 6 committee and
also the doj at this point that she was
tampered with right right
if you if you don't believe that the
witness tampering that happened with
cassidy hutchinson didn't get reported
to the doj you're not paying attention
it definitely did because witness
tampering is a very very very very very
uh high felony that they love to
prosecute especially if they can prove
it now here's the thing
there were two individuals who were very
close to trump especially in this scheme
to overturn the uh the government of the
united states
in january of 2020.
their names are jeffrey clark and john
eastman
we know that they're cell phones their
[__] cell phones were targeted
you don't think you don't believe that
maybe those cell phones hold that
witness tampering evidence right you got
to be out of your [__] mind if you
don't understand what is happening and
you can see the case that not only
january 6 select committee but the
department of justice the department of
justice sees those phones
so if you can't see that the january 6
select committee is going hey here's
evan it's a tampering they hand it over
to doj doj axe grabs those [__]
phones you're not paying attention
you're not paying attention now
it goes to bego why haven't we gotten
donald trump's phone
i don't know maybe that's the reason why
they're distracting us with ashley
babbitt and hunter biden here right i
mean they did go down and seize 15 boxes
worth of classified documents and we
still don't here's the thing i don't
think that the
um
the national archives team has actually
given that over
because i know that it was requested by
the january 6 committee and i think
benny thompson was like we requested but
we were denied
right well and i mean that's that's
typical government that's typical
government agency stuff that i mean who
knows maybe there's a video that comes
out sometime before
the next hearing and
and maybe talks about what was in those
15 boxes are you saying we might have
some evidence
it might be found footage okay you know
okay well you know what we should also
find we should also find those
voicemails
yes i bet there's voicemails on eastman
and and clark's phone or some other
phones maybe yeah or maybe even the
phone that was the the that trump was
calling right maybe because here's the
other thing too that people aren't
realizing is that they're like oh it was
a butt dial da da
okay let's say that trump did die that
that didn't but dial this person right
how would the committee know
and how would the person on the
receiving end know that trump was trying
to talk to them and have like and commit
witness tampering right you don't just
butt dial you'd hear some conversations
like oh that's weird i got a weird phone
call from donald trump right right you'd
hear swish swish swish swish swish
because he would probably have it like
the mcdonald's
golfing
like i love a golden shower you know if
you hear stuff like that like down there
and
that would be it and you wouldn't you
wouldn't think anything of it but you
also wouldn't think like oh this guy's
calling me to uh intimidate me or or
talk about the the trial right or the
the the investigation
it would only right because because a
butt dial and a butt a butt dial
voicemail right
yeah you're saying but here's the thing
they didn't answer the phone liz cheney
said they did not answer the phone and
they referred it to the committee as
well as the doj which means that the
only way
that they would know this was witness
tampering is if donald trump and his
[__] dumb ass orange fat ogre body
decided to leave a voicemail
from his phone or even if it wasn't his
phone it's clearly donald trump's voice
and calling from mar-a-lago saying hey
you know i hear you're gonna be on the
uh in front of the committee uh gonna
give a deposition just remember i love
you and be loyal like he's gonna say
some dumb [__] like saying [__] like
that but what he cannot help himself
from doing that you know what we should
do we should try to dig these voicemails
up we can't find these things yeah i'm
pretty sure we can find what we should
do is we should publish them once we
find them yeah so that way journalists
out there really good journalist who
doesn't drive a lot of background they
do a lot of research on things that they
see on the internet that they can see it
and really spread it around yeah you
know that's what they should do yeah who
knows maybe maybe for tomorrow's show
you know we'll have some voicemails
maybe maybe actually speaking of
voicemail i want to go to the [__] list
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends here
because i have a voicemail i want your
opinion on it's marjorie taylor green
about rigging elections maybe so let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
the [__] list
welcome back back to the show we have
reached the part of the show where we
round up all the tweety tweets in the
trendy trends called the [__] list
roundup
this is the voicemail or it's a
voicemail recording i'm not sure what
this is it's kind of cut up uh katie
katie posted said this should be bigger
news uh the account a proud progressive
posted this video it's got 34 000 views
so it's spreading around a little bit
now i'm not sure what it is right it
says here here's marjorie taylor green
telling a donor to commit voter fraud by
temporary by using a temporary georgia
address
now this video is cut okay and that's
what makes me suspicious about it in the
first place it is a little cut up but
let's listen to the phone call
uh it's only 24 seconds we might have to
listen to it a couple times but i want
to get your opinion on what you think
about this yeah yeah say you voted in
california so you voted in california
for the general election if you wanted
to you could move to georgia temporarily
just move here
in a little place all you need is one
like a a bill any uh
um and so you know in your social
security card and you can go get a
georgia driver's license and register to
vote and you can vote in our senate
races and
so okay so it feels like to me that the
audio is a little cut it may be it may
not be i don't yeah yeah
so she's talking sorry can we go can we
just pull it back on the screen we can
keep talking i just want to pull back on
the screen real quick can you can you
scrub through there i want to see
er
okay wait up
oh if i'll go back
it's okay so we have a 24 minute call
and that's the number seven wait
seven seven zero six zero five two zero
three six so let's just say live on the
air what if i were to call this number
hey look look look we're uh we're going
we're going to do investigative
journalism seven seven zero
six zero five
two zero three six all right i'll put it
on speakerphone let's see what happens
you [__] if she picks up the phone
i'm sure they've gotten thousands of
phone calls this morning
hello hello
your call has been forwarded to an
automatic voice message system i'll
leave a voicemail
zero 7-0-6-0-5-2-0-3 six is not
available
hi marjorie taylor green is this you
just wanted to call and confirm as we
have you live on the tony michael show
right now uh we noticed that there was a
phone call that came from you to someone
allegedly telling them to commit voter
fraud just wanted to get a quote from
you give me a call back at
708.21 oh i'm not gonna tell my number
uh
at the number that's on the caller id
yeah yeah
uh all right well good talking to you
bye
there we go hopefully we'll get a
response from from old marge uh to give
us a statement here at the tony michaels
podcast on this video that seems to be
her saying hey
hey
go commit voter fraud now again
to me this is a 24 minute call right so
we don't in this 24 seconds we don't
know what was said the 24 minutes before
this correct we just don't know right
but here's the thing
is i could i could see where
she is saying this is what democrats
tried to do right before this little
diatribe mm-hmm like and she's
describing some kind of weird-ass
conspiracy theory
because frankly this is [__]
boneheaded [__] yeah to think that
people are gonna spend all their money
to to pack their [__] and temporarily
move because you're not talking about
just
renting
the way she says renting a place you
actually have to provide permanent
residence right you have to change your
idea you have to change your voting
status
i mean there's [__] that has to be done
to do that and it's not just like you
rent a place in georgia and act like
you're there permanently yeah right i
mean i guess i guess you uh one could do
that like mark meadows but it wouldn't i
mean it could it would be voter fraud
who knows you know she might be uh
giving this advice to people like um
herschel walker it could be well i mean
he is a carpet bagger for sure he does
not live in georgia yep um have you
received a phone call back yet and from
march for a statement i really would
like to get her statement if we could
get a phone call back that sucks yeah i
wish she would i wish she would have
answered she could just answer the phone
it'd be great yeah it would be great
[Laughter]
you would [__] if that's your real cell
phone number wouldn't you yeah that's cr
so let me just google this really quick
it was seven seven zero
uh six zero five two zero three six is
the number on this video that's the
number on the video
i don't know
let's see seven seven zero it's a
georgia number that's one thing
uh oh rat row that's the right spot
all right i'll keep looking but yeah why
you're looking there because again oh
[__] what
that is her number
are you [__] [__] me hold on all
right according to
oh boy oh boy oh boy
what is this number hold on
[Laughter]
oh
marjorie taylor green
marjorie taylor yes crossfit passion
11445 north fulton industrial boulevard
alpharetta georgia three zero zero zero
nine seven seven zero six zero five two
zero three six margaery green
crossfit passion
gmail.com
[Laughter]
so
this is a confirmation here on the tony
michael's podcast
as best as we can with the research that
we have at hand
that this phone call
on this screen here
that number is her number yeah on this
on this video
now again it is hard to tell in this
video to be honest with you gabe it is
hard to tell in this video
if this is audio from another call and
they're just
you know putting it on this video
because you can do that right we know
you can cut a video right cut the audio
from something else and put it on there
so
again
i want everyone to question this video
right
i want them to question this video
that's what i want you to do
because we don't know what was said to
24 minutes before but it appears
it appears at first glance that marjorie
taylor green
is actually
trying to convince people on the phone
to commit voter fraud
it's weird stuff it's weird stuff
can you imagine being a politician and
have to call
thousands and thousands of people to
convince them to commit this type of
voter fraud so that you can win
this is really weird stuff yeah who
knows maybe 24 minutes before and 24
minutes after i don't know how long she
was on the phone to sell them
hey
uh you should commit voter fraud and
this is how you do it go to this place
rent a little apartment or a space or
get a p.o box or whatever it is
you know
well let's listen let's listen to the
tape one more time let's listen to it
one more time so say you voted in
california so you voted in california
for the general election if you wanted
to you could move to georgia temporarily
just move here
in a little place all you need is one
like a bill any uh
um and so you know in your social
security card and you can go get a
georgia driver's license and register a
vote and you could vote in our senate
races
and
so say you voted one more time
california so you voted in california
for the general election if you wanted
to you could move to georgia temporarily
just move here with rent a little place
all you need is one like a a bill any uh
um and so you know in your social
security card and you can go get a
georgia driver's license and register to
vote and you could vote in our senate
races and
so marjorie taylor green have you got uh
gabe's voicemail please contact us here
at the tony michael's podcast you can
email us you can go the other so i've
been i've been continuing to dig into
this yeah what
so it's no longer called crossfit
passion it's called united performance
ftc still same location but different
number so i don't know i'm i'm not sure
in terms of like what the transfer of
ownership or the new name or what the
what the for the phone number for the
phone for the phone number but also for
the business so it's still a crossfit
gym but i don't remember if she
sold i don't know if she soldered it or
like you know let's see
so let's
because everyone's in the comments
i want to i want everyone to understand
that this video can be edited to make it
look this way
i i said allegedly right i think i
actually
believe that this video could be real
but that's why we want marge to make a
statement here she needs to get out and
make a statement and
do a press release rather this phone
call's real or not
i really want her to
let's let's get her to make a statement
rather this goddamn voicemail's real or
not
i mean obviously she'll lie more just
like she lies about everything else i
mean she continuing has been proved to
be a a liar
i mean and she's continuing to
continue to
do stupid [__] that a congress person
shouldn't be doing like if this is real
if this is if this video is real of her
actually trying to get someone to commit
voter fraud
in georgia yeah man i think i think
there are authorities that would like to
see this and hear this and see what her
statement is on this
i would believe maybe just maybe but but
here's the thing
we left her a voicemail hopefully
hopefully she'll get back to gabe see if
we can yeah we'll see i don't know i'm
starting to think that the number no
longer
i mean like the name still comes up in
searches for crossfit passion
so in other words they may have gotten
rid of the phone number
possibly but they they changed the name
so like if i look up map quest which is
a throwback for people uh i'm still
getting seven seven yeah seven seven
zero nine ninety nine it is i'm going to
print this out in a second
uh but then if i go online and i look
other places it says that it changed its
name to
[Music]
um
was
it was passion crossfit or crossfire
passion and then became
united performance and their number is
different their 470 number number
very interesting very interesting well
marge if you got if you can hear us and
you got our voicemail get back with us
and let us know what you think of this
video and spreading around the internet
we really want to know we are very
curious if this video is real or not
and if it is fake tell us why it is and
i want you to prove it that's what i
want you to do um
so thank you kd uh for pointing this out
here uh to me so that we could you know
track this down a bit that's what we do
here at the tony michaels podcast um you
know we
we're we're not we're not just sell
proclaim satirist and commentary
we actually trying to do a little bit of
due diligence right do a little bit of
due diligence
just just want to get just want to get
an idea you know like i said i let the
voicemail i said allegedly
you know just looking for a quote i was
like if i just want to see what her
response is okay so let's go to we we
missed a video yeah there we missed a
couple videos yesterday uh i was super
pissed about this uvaldi video that was
released and not just the video that was
released but going back and watching
greg abbott's prior statements where he
[__] lied about it watching the city
council tape where they [__] um they
they demean
the media for releasing the tape that
shows that those uh police officers were
cowards
and i don't want to spend too much more
time on that because i want to get to
some video that is important here now
one of them is this video
of josh holly getting his ass handed to
him and i believe this happened on july
12th so this happened on tuesday
is when this happened the recount here
has a a clip of it from the pbs uh news
hour
um but this professor that you're going
to see
uh kyra bridges and she's uh from
berkeley i believe correct is that right
i believe yeah she's a uc berkeley yeah
uc berkeley professor and she's there to
talk about reproductive rights um and
she's a witness josh holly is a senator
in that committee so he has the right as
a senator
afforded to him by his constituents to
ask her questions
uh because she is a witness now he's a
[__] transphobe homophobe he's a pile
of [__] he's a fascist
racist misogynist
and the list goes on and on and on here
seditionist traitor
law professor bridges
absolutely
wads him up and dumps him in the [__]
trash here right you have to see this
video so let's go the video here um and
i may want to again watch the part where
she slam dunks him a couple times so
bear with me you've referred to people
with a capacity for pregnancy
would that be women just the actual
disdain of this [__] towards
towards
you smug [__] you smug son of a
[__] it really pisses me off that he's
the senator from my state to be honest
yeah that piece of [__] how he's holding
that pencil act like he's going to stab
somebody you [__] okay let's continue
i'm so triggered he is he is he is he is
triggered let's watch
many women cis women have the capacity
for pregnancy many cis women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy um there are
also trans men who are capable of
pregnancy as well as non-binary people
who are capable of pregnancy so the boom
boom this is the [__] matte wall [__]
they say that [__] dreaming too
because he was like oh she can't say
what a woman is you can't either you
piece of [__]
you that's why you made a movie that's
called what is a woman because you
clearly do not know right you clearly do
not know that a
woman
is a gender that someone identifies as
you [__] bonehead but watch this is
now she starts here
watch as she picks him a [__] apart
watch this isn't really a women's rights
issue it's uh we can recognize that this
impacts women while also recognizing
that it impacts other groups those
things are not mutually exclusive
senator hawley oh so your view is is
that the core of this this right then is
about what
um i want to recognize that your line of
questioning um is transphobic um and it
opens up trans people to violence you've
referred to
you are a piece of [__] [__] that's
what i i mean i mean you know this is
why i can't go be [__]
a witness in congress
i wouldn't last two seconds in the
[__] room with a guy like josh hawley
they would kick me out and you are a
[__] piece of [__] number one number
one can i get this all on the record
here you are a great piece of [__]
[__]
they just they wouldn't have me in the
room for very long
but the way she basically tells josh
holly you are inciting violence against
these people just by this line of
questioning because you know
you know the truthy piece of [__] you
know the truth you're just it's just
your political expedience and your
fascism that
that allows you to want to continue this
line of questioning to put trans people
and women in danger you [__]
yeah
and and i love how she pointed it out
just slam dunks him in the trash so that
was the that was the video yesterday
that we missed from josh hawley i know a
lot of people wanted to watch that we
just we actually went over like i don't
know 20 minutes yesterday and we still
didn't have time i know i know to get to
that holly hip
holly clip
that college they call it i'm confused
[__]
have you gotten a phone call back i'm
i'm still hoping you get a call right
here
i really believe that the number no like
it still works so i don't know where
it's going
like
we'll keep talking i'm gonna call this
other number
okay it's a crossfit gym which if i had
to guess in my head
then the other number still is
registered but isn't working because the
other crossfit gym is open and i would
imagine that if somebody called they'd
have a voicemail that says like hey
welcome to you know united performance
fitness blah blah blah blah like they
would have something to catch you you
know well a lot of times a lot of times
they're like a business they'll have a
business phone and then they'll have
another business phone that they have
like a cell phone yeah
to get in touch with someone who is in
charge of that business where you know
the business phone is someone who calls
inquiring about hours and that sort of
thing right here's another video i want
i think we missed uh yesterday of
scabby face steve bannon he seems really
defeated here in this clip and he's he's
completely he's slowly uh
just kind of decaying yeah
who knows he might decay all the way
before he gets inside of jail like
before he even sees prison bars he might
have just like
like
you know kind of like a blob like half
on the ground melted and he's like
yeah
you know like nothing nothing really
coming out just like bubbles of of goo
popping
that's what i imagine would probably
happen so here's i want to point out
what i was talking about earlier about
his signs behind him here
you know here's this one it says there
are no conspiracies but there are no
coincidence and he's got his name so
he's got his own quote back right right
and then he's got this other and says we
can do hard things
you can do hard time that's for sure
you can definitely do hard time but the
best part about this [__] behind him is
the jesus stuff
like where did he get this where did he
get this is like like a [__] garage
sale or something look at this jesus
this looks like the jesus like uh so my
grandparents used to have uh
this jesus
painting
right kind of whatever very religious
very cute yeah yeah right is it yep
exactly
and they had it as you were going down
the stairs he would just stare at you as
you were coming down the stairs would
his eyes follow you like like yeah yeah
pretty yeah they would follow you but
also like the stairs were uh the the
the difference in height was much
shorter like as i got older it was like
one of those like i had to duck under
you know so i'm getting like real close
to like just going underneath jesus to
avoid him
but as soon as you're at the island this
is the jesus picture is this the one it
looks pretty similar you know i think
they all kind of look the same so it
just
triggers that memory in you with the
right right so yeah whenever we'd go to
their house
uh on my mom's side it would always be
there and i would always make a joke
about it um
and yeah it's just like you know it's
standard stuff you see the guys see the
halo in long hair the red robe white
white shirt you know hey i grew up i
grew up a catholic
just like you and almost every house you
know family member or or or parishioner
you know fellow parishioner that was a
member of the church go to their house
or whatever
they always have the last supper right
yeah likes have that
you know and there's different versions
of it yeah the first panorama we call it
you know right right right and and and
it's all white people in that yeah yeah
yeah [__] painting and if any of
those people would have been white at
all no no no not just jesus but all of
them are white in that [__] in that
painting um so yeah i know exactly what
you're talking about with the jesus
stuff and the crosses on the wall and
the the last supper the picture of jesus
uh you know the lord's prayer was all
over walls too i think i think we even
actually had one in our house when i was
growing up we had the our father prayer
um and i think it was like on a wood
plank where it was carved in right and
that was the that was the prayer on the
water yeah our father i luckily did not
have any of that type of stuff in my
house growing up yeah but i you know i
went to catholic grade school so i had
plenty of that for eight years you had
that imagery and you had that yeah yeah
everywhere i went you know you guys go
to mass every every day yeah every day
yeah we went to a 30 minute mass we went
there yeah 30 minute mass man that's
that's humping it man well i mean that's
that's 30 minutes we went in you know so
i forget
after uh
i forget what grade we started doing
confession right yeah so that was how
many hail marys did you have what was
the most oh i don't know every time
you know exactly how many 15 hail marys
and four-hour fathers like every time i
would go in there it was always like as
a kid they're like so what do you have
to like what do you feel guilty about
because that's what the question was
what do you feel guilty about that you
need to tell me about so now throughout
my did you ever tell them the worst
things that you did or just like no i'm
quasi i would just be like oh my brother
and i got in a fight or i did this or
whatever you know i would also it's like
uh look i know that you're supposed to
like not supposed to be tell be telling
people stuff you know like because
that's like the the agreement that we
have in this confessional not that i
would have anything really bad to talk
about but as a kid you're like oh god
well i feel really guilty about this and
now throughout my whole adult life i
feel this catholic guilt it has never
left me i will forever have it i will
always feel guilty about the dumbest
smallest oh i know here's the thing
here's a big audience
audience i want you to know that in
private meetings with me and gabe he
does he has a lot of catholic guilt and
i point it out yeah i always point it
out to him i'm just like always pointed
out 40 lashes to myself
i think the most hail mary's and then
we'll move on to scabby scabby scabby
steve here
um the most almerians i think i ever had
to um
to do
to
wash myself of my sin
was i i actually think they made me do
like 80 or 90 at one point
yeah wow i'm not going to say wow i'm
not going to say what the sin was but
yeah well you know i have this i have
this instinct to just say whatever the
[__] comes to mind so when i got into
the confessional you know i was i was
admitting everything you know though
yeah whole nine yards yeah why not like
forgive me father it has been one week
since i've last met he's like whoa whoa
you did all that in a week right right
since yesterday no my confession was
yesterday
he's like jesus christ the last 24 hours
90 hail mary's son yes i think i think
80 or 90 was at literally and it was
i i never did the exact amount yeah yeah
yeah
i mean the other thing i mean you sit
down you're like oh you get through that
and you're like yeah i'm a speed player
you're right you know like people are
faster i'm a speed prayer right right
right but the other thing too is um yeah
i would totally i think someone else
asked in the chat they're like did
anyone else make stuff up i'm 100
i would make stuff up just be like well
i got nothing i literally have nothing
to feel sorry for because i didn't do
anything or at least in my mind yeah
yeah yeah okay so be like oh yeah no i
totally uh
didn't leave the toilet seat down you
know like
dumb stuff and they were like okay okay
okay well say to our fathers and four
hail marys and go over in the pew and
sit down and i'm like oh god finally i'm
out of this place it's a really long
story but i was i actually left the
catholic church when i was a teenager
during my confirmation because of the
pro-choice issue and and maybe one of
these days i'll i'll tell the story to
the audience yeah somewhere like
mid-confirmation
mid-confirmation like the ceremony i
told them to go [__] themselves no not
during the ceremony during the classes
during the two years
i told them to go [__] themselves
on the on women's rights is basically
what i did so it's a big long story but
that's where me and the catholic church
had a big disagreement who knows maybe
we'll do a sunday episode oh like a
sunday mass yeah like a sunday mass yeah
right right maybe maybe maybe but but
that is something that me and gabe have
in common i know a lot of our audience
probably has in common out there that
you were a member of the catholic church
or or another very dogmatic church and
now maybe your faith isn't quite as
strong i'm an atheist and i know i think
gabe is yeah i'm not i don't
right no no yeah but that dogma really
does it to you doesn't it so let's get
back to the dogma of scabby steve here
um past his dogma behind him that's a
ridiculous stuff i i even forget what
he's saying in this clip but he is he's
getting a little scared because this is
after the judge has told him that he's
going to go to trial
and this morning we have more news um
there's some news that the judge is
still saying no because he's trying to
he's trying to submit more and more
uh ways to get out of going to trial
right and the reason why is because
steve bannon's gonna probably be locked
up in prison uh before the midterm which
is really bad for steve bannon really
bad for donald trump and and that's
probably part of his pardon agreement is
he has to try to extend this [__] as
long as he possibly can and what i mean
by that is the trade the quid pro quo
why trump pardoned him from the from the
fraud case
that where he stole the money from the
people who were trying to build the wall
build the wall so let's listen to how
scared scabby steve is here reaching out
to me for the last couple of days about
prayers and pray look we all love prayer
or something like that but here's what
i've been telling folks
pray for our enemies
okay so he's gonna go with the religious
thing here
he's gonna go with the religious thing
so maybe it's appropriate that he has
the white jesus behind him let's find
out what what he wants to pray
about his enemies which i guess it would
be me and you
and all of our audience i guess anyone
who's pro-democracy and anti-fascist
yeah at this point would be his enemies
so let's listen to how he wants to pray
for them i wonder if they're hail mary's
okay pray for cause we're going to
medieval on these people we're going to
savage our enemies so pray for them
that's who needs prayers
not magga not war room and certainly not
stephen k bannon but i'll take
everything i can get
wait a second did he say we're going to
go medieval on them
yeah yeah yeah it sounds really not
christian to pray
to for your in it sounds like he's he's
right it sounds it it sounds like he's
you know he's like oh no i don't you
know i'll take what well first off he's
like i'll take what i can get which is
like i don't need your [__] prayers i
need your money right right right but
when he goes in and he's well that's
what the white jesus is for being right
well hey give me money because i believe
in white jesus because what he's also
saying here he's like oh
uh
these people should be seeking mercy
from us right because we'll go medieval
we'll go savage on them you know
whatever bring it on just bring it on
bring it up yeah okay well we'll see if
you're still around by the way right
when your cold bare feet are hitting a
[__] concrete floor in federal prison
we'll talk
let's listen which i feel like you would
also have a ton like if you went to jail
a prison like i feel like he would
really fit in with the you know white
supremacists that are either guards
or that are inmates so i feel like
he would have a voice there you know
they would probably give him his own
radio show if they wanted to well here's
the thing i believe this
if steve bannon gets convicted of this
charge of contempt to congress which
looks like he will now the judge has
said this morning or yesterday in the
last decision that the judge made the
judge does have a little bit of angst
about getting a fair jury to have a fair
trial right but he says we're going to
go through the process and we're going
to get the fairest jury we possibly can
for this trial because that's what steve
bannon and donald trump have been trying
to do all this time they know they're
going to get indicted they know they're
going to go to [__] federal criminal
court that's why they're trying to
cast doubt and disparagement and trying
to taint any jury pool that would be out
there that's what they're trying to do
so that the federal courts feel like
they don't have a decision but to
release the charges because they can't
try them based on a fair jury which is
not going to be the case a judge is
going to find a fair jury for these
trials now i believe steve bannon is
going to be easily convicted of this
contempt charge of congress the other
charges are much more difficult some of
the other stuff that's going to be
brought depending on the evidence that
we actually see but this condemn charge
is very easy the reason why it's so
important and why donald trump and steve
bannon are so [__] concerned about
this is because he cannot do his
propaganda
like he's doing now from federal prison
it's just not a possibility because
steve bannon isn't going to go to like a
high security federal prison he'll
probably go to a low security federal
prison for this charge right for this
particular charge now
he does have a past history of violence
he does have a past history of of other
some other legal issues and criminal
issues so it is likely it is likely that
a judge will sentence him to at least
half of the of the the maximum
which is two years so he'll probably get
anywhere between 8 and 16 months
on this charge if he's convicted would
be my that would be my guess but if you
do the math on that he has to serve on
especially if he gets eight months
anything up to 12 months he's gonna have
to serve that entire [__] sentence
yeah that entire sentence he'll have to
serve so if he gets nine months or ten
months or four months but here's the
thing that really is going to eat into
the midterm strategy of the propaganda
machine here and that's the key that's
why they're [__] a little terrified
here is because steve bannon won't be
able to run point guard on the [__]
fascist propaganda machine because that
is where the point is happening
is this [__] vile ass show war room
on trader tv network
that this is the point this is the
person who's running point for their
entire hateful propaganda machine and
the reason why is because you know that
steve bannon knows the deep dark web
from his days at breitbart that's how
they cultivated breitbart in the first
place yeah and steve bannon knows this
that's why trump brought steve bannon on
to the campaign the same way with
kellyanne conway as they understand the
marketing they understand the whole
thing so
but let's finish what scabby steve here
has to say about being defeated in court
but put ahead in the cap table put our
enemies in front because that's who's
really going to need prayers okay
because we're going medieval okay um and
we'll see about this committee what
happens this afternoon but hey my offer
is out there
here's what i need
give me a date a time a room number a
microphone and a holy bible i can take
the oath on oh cause that makes a big
difference i'm sure i'm sure there's no
way steve bannon would put his hand on
the bible and swear to the white jesus
behind him that he will not lie and lie
i'm sure that's not even a possibility
gabe
give me a [__] break what's be with
the best part about this is is if his
audience had any kind of [__]
principle here yeah about about you [__]
the select committee and all that
[__] you know america and trump
it's all a witch hunt and all that
nonsense if they had any kind of
principle which they don't have any
principles whatsoever that's why they're
able to fall for all this garbage yes
they would actually turn on him here
when he's saying oh yeah i'll come
testify because now my ass is in a
ringer because i lost a court case right
my ass is going to go to trial and i'm
well lost the court case and kept losing
a court case because every time he's
tried to the judge is like yeah [__] you
yeah right well because it's it's
ridiculous right it's [__] red his
argument's ridiculous and really the
judge tore apart every single argument
they had
so much so that before this was credited
his attorney said in open court well
what's the point even going to trial we
don't have a defense
right so this morning in in the judge's
decision he gave him one or two ways to
defend himself here
at least to mount some defense to a jury
because the judge totally destroyed that
in the decision the other day
so the judge has given him a few points
to go on but really it's just that steve
bannon is a bonehead and he doesn't
understand what subpoenas are and he
misunderstood the date which is really
stupid because that's not what happened
and and the best evidence is the
prosecution is gonna use this show where
he was talking about [__] the select
committee and [__] him i ain't gonna
tell him a goddamn thing yeah and on and
on and on he goes let's finish
boom deliver that and we'll see how good
you are little jamie raskin and liz
cheney and all of it
serve it up you've got my here's my
date time room number
uh microphone that works and uh and a
holy bible to take the oath on okay they
already did all that
they did all that and you said [__] you
because you
you probably were tampered with by a
certain individual who butt dials people
hmm i wonder if that was the case hmm
i wonder
what a dumb buck what an absolute dumb
buck
to gaslight not only his audience but
the entire united states of america you
know what do you expect i mean right
he's you know he'll he's a rat and he'll
do whatever he can you know i mean he's
like he's kind of well he's like a
possum right if he's corner he's gonna
[__] lash out right if nothing goes
again if he feels like the the the tide
is turning you know he's going to do
whatever he can to save his own ass
even if it means throw other people
within the party under the bus like 100
percent he would do that
absolutely
well the same way with donald trump i
mean they're cut from the same cloth
they're cut from this cloth
of the gop the death cult that they are
have you've seen this video
of this [__] attorney general from
indiana this piece of [__] [__] i
have not watched this i know this is
about i have not watched this one yet
so everyone isn't um up to speed there's
a 10 year old girl
who was raped by her father and was
pregnant in the state of ohio because
roe v wade was overturned and ohio had
trigger laws
and she's no longer able to receive
abortion services
after her father raped her because
there's not exceptions for that she's a
10 year old this is a little child
okay
these people [__] claim save the
children save the children it's all
about children stop messing with the
children
well tucker carlson and all these
[__] went on the news uh jim
jordan tweeted about it and since has
deleted that tweet that it was all fake
and it was the it was the house gop
account retweeted it
yeah the official account right not some
[__] obscure account that's got a lot
of [__] followers what is their
official account that retweeted the [__]
and i think i've got an image of that
thing um that we can pull up here but
here's the thing is that it turned it
turned out cape that story was true
oh
because here was everyone kept saying
well if it's true then they would arrest
the rapist right right like that's what
they continued to say
they did arrest the rapist
they did now the rapist is an
undocumented person i believe i believe
that's the case so now they're making it
all about that right
nothing to do with the little child that
was raped
that can't receive a goddamn procedure
to make sure that a little baby girl
doesn't have to carry her father's baby
because she was raped you stupid
bastards of forced [__] pregnancy on
a child
is what we're talking about here
and listen to this [__] piece of [__]
attorney general in indiana of who he
wants to go after listen to this
so what's going on todd
jesse thanks for having me i want to
point out at the chiron at the bottom
the lower third here
uh jesse waters and fox news point out
illegal charge with rape of a
ten-year-old right
yep that's the case why haven't you
apologized for lying to the american
people with your other chirons the two
days before when you were saying it was
a fake story you muth the [__]
what and and to call it illegal is gross
in and of itself but let's listen it
gets grosser about the 10 year old
little baby who are they oh the state of
ohio and now the attorney general of
indiana want to force this child to have
a baby but i shouldn't be here right i
mean first of all
this is an illegal immigration
issue because
nope nope nope that's a completely
different issue that's a completely
different issue this issue of this girl
receiving this service this little baby
girl receiving this service so she
doesn't have to carry her father rapist
baby all the way to full term because
you [__] boneheads are are hell bent
on killing people and killing children
no it's not an issue of the illegal
immigrants we're not gonna we're not
gonna play the game of well they gotta
do the brown people thing you know this
all too well in your comments with this
stuff you you make a video about
something and then it's about your race
right right exactly where you can go
back to you which is chicago i believe
yeah yeah and then ice they they hope
ice will deport me to chicago yeah dude
to the suburbs of chicago the insane
stuff i've seen people but this is what
this is as soon as this person's picture
was released they jumped all over it as
soon as they found out that this person
was undocumented they jumped all over it
right which that may be an issue i don't
know but we're not talking about the
[__] issue of him being undocumented
we're talking about him being arrested
and charged with the crime of raping a
10 year old which he should be
we're talking about the [__] absolute
vile
policy that you [__] have put
into place to put this little 10 year
old girl's life in danger
because you want to force her to carry a
baby to full term
where her father raped her let's listen
it's likely of biden's lawlessness at
the border oh my god and everything
going on down there that's why indiana
as a non-border state has actually filed
several independent lawsuits on that
then we have the rape and then we have
this abortion activist
acting as a doctor with a history of
failing to report
number one the rape is not in his
jurisdiction this is the attorney
general of indiana this little girl was
raped in ohio now all the republicans
including this [__] attorney general
in indiana probably said oh that's not
real no way is that real 10 year old
that bit is [__] fake it's just
they're like this is this left machine
making up [__] to stoke fear and blah
blah blah we do not have to make up [__]
to stoke fear yeah we don't have to make
up [__] that's what you [__] do
you project yeah these people
project to be like this will never
happen blah blah you know they'll go one
they'll go on and [__] die try about
how this is never possible won't happen
it is a complete fantasy world that
democrats want to live and it's like no
we do not want to live in a world where
this happens and then when that little
girl seeks
aid and help you say
can't do it yeah they want to punish her
they want to [__] punish her well
let's listen how he wants to punish her
because he not only wants to punish her
he wants to punish the person who's
trying to help this this little baby
girl not have to carry her rapist
[__] baby to full term which could
poss i mean a 10 year old carrying a
baby to full term i don't even know how
viable that pregnancy is gonna be i mean
again i'm a man i'm a man i didn't i
grew up as a boy i don't know these sort
of things so i stay in my [__] lane
which is out of the lane of [__]
women's bodies in their autonomy okay
but also just to like you know trying to
imagine the
the size and
overall body of a ten-year-old to be
like oh we're gonna now throw
um something that you know will
obviously
change the physical nature of your body
add weight to you where you're like
not sure what the [__] is happening
emotions and everything changing
and not able to express yourselves
properly because you don't really
understand
what this is right what's going on and
why would you want to put a little kid
to that whatever it is right like
to imagine like 11 12 13 40 like
whatever the age range
like mentally
a child a little girl is not
is not ready
to accept that weight right physically
and emotionally right and mentally
but we're probably like no well it's the
the guy in the sky said you gotta have
that baby
well no it's i'm i'm a very powerful
white man and i'm gonna force you to
have the baby because it only it only is
for my political gain to say that we
are going to value every quote unquote
life right here or believe or believe
like oh it was god's will was it god's
will really that this terrible thing
happened to this little girl and that
it's god's will that you're gonna force
them to have a child this isn't mary
this is one [__] immaculate
conception this is all
this is a real thing that happened to an
actual little girl not some [__]
fantasy book about some guy he was a
traveling magician
and made people believe things
and then now you're gonna say that you
believe in in christ and but do the
complete opposite right this is the
party that is complete projection it is
complete uh uh hypocrites it is complete
like people that just go against what
they preach right
well let's watch the rest of this vile
piece of [__] say what he's going to say
because we only got a few more seconds
of it but it it is a lot of grossness in
a few seconds
so we're gathering the information we're
gathering the evidence as we speak and
we're going to fight this
to the end
including looking at her licensure
if she failed to report in indiana it's
a crime
for uh to not report to intentionally
not report
yeah they make they make it that these
[__] fascists make a lot of [__] into
crime um you know that that way that way
they can take away your rights right
they do a lot of things to make things
into crimes to take away your [__]
rights especially rights away from a
little bitty girl
to seek
an abortion service because she was
raped and now has to carry the states
forcing her
to carry forced a big government is
to carry this baby uh here i want to
show you
a couple days before that clip you had
uh tucker carlson on fox news um because
aoc actually tweeted about this this
story and about this case of this 10
year old
um but
we'll see we'll see here how tucker
uh not only puts his foot in the mouth
but seems to just like detach his leg
and stick the entire thing down yeah he
just goes full
just unhinges the jaw really goes for it
right he should tan his balls a little
more maybe that'll help but let's listen
so what does it tell us that politicians
are lying about this can you imagine and
why did the bible can you imagine if
politicians lie no one could ever
imagine a republican politician or a
republican a republican on tv would lie
about something can you even [__]
imagine
the projection the projection oh my god
you [__] let's listen administration
speaking of lying just repeat a story
about a ten-year-old child who got
pregnant
and they got an abortion or was not
allowed to get an abortion when it turns
out the story was not true and by the
way when a ten-year-old gets pregnant
the first question is not how do we get
rid of the kid the first question is
where's the rapist where's the rapist
alice uh well they arrested him tucker
so where's your retraction there you
little
[__] yeah what a little but also the
timeline too is like i think they were
notified
at the
like in the
june 20th range 22nd 24th or something
like that and they didn't do anything
uh
you mean you mean uh i thought i thought
i read that authorities were notified
of what had happened
in june and nobody did anything uh let
me see if i can find it
well again again the reports are that he
has been arrested the story's confirmed
at this point and really if if tucker
carlson or fox news wanted to act like
the president united states hadn't
tracked down that information and made
sure that [__] was correct before they
put it in a speech i mean i'm not saying
that the administration or any
administration gets it right every
single time but jesus christ come on
right they definitely wanted to make
sure there was confirmation of that
story because it really
honestly on its face it feels so [__]
gross that it's untrue right like right
jesus but also it's the fact that
yeah yeah okay so it said ohio's
attorney general went on foxes to smear
a 10 year old rape victim and today the
columbus cops announced the rapist had
been a suspect since june 22 and he was
arraigned today
so the real story here is you know them
trying to blame it on someone else when
it's their own incompetence
that they said
oh well he was a suspect since june 22nd
this was a real thing a police report
was filed you don't just [__] just
say so wait wait wait you're saying a
journalist could actually seek out and
see if there's evidence like a yeah like
a crazy report i know oh my god it's
almost like the white house probably
went and looked at some evidence of a
police report being filed against a a
rape against a 10 year old and now she's
turning up pregnant oh my god it would
be right
it'd be so hard to probably get that
information i don't know if you just did
your [__] job yeah tucker [__] them
exactly
you know and speaking of tucker carlson
there's this guy here and 50 shades of
wings oh god this is [__] alex stein
this [__] guy this [__] guy oh my
god he goes he's he's a frequent visitor
of tucker carlson as he goes on a lot of
right-wing
i bet he's hand balls he doesn't tan his
face but i bet he tans his balls what do
you think
oh one hundred percent 100 as soon as
that documentary that quote-unquote
documentary came out from tucker carlson
originals
um
he was the first in line to be at that
camp
spread eagle
get those tiny little balls and a little
pecker in there and try to get as much
red light as he could to be like i'm a
real man
what this this video that you're going
to see has a lot of little dick energy a
lot a little dick energy and really it
murders i don't know if you've seen the
comments on this stuff but holy [__]
you posted this on instagram and it's oh
oh he posted this and he posted on
instagram and she took it from him and i
think
that's why she cropped it is because
underneath it said his his handle
so she cropped that out i think to be
like look at this dude but i don't want
to give any more yeah fifty shades fifty
shades says retweet or embed tweeted
this video from aoc
yep from aoc i just retweeted his
because that's the one i saw it off of
so i reached it make sure we talked
about it today but this alex stein he
really is a tucker carlson type it looks
like he has a whole
bow tie collection oh yeah in
commemoration of tucker carlson this
[__] guy now if anyone isn't aware
who this is
there were uh the last uh cpac remember
when uh there was this big huge shooting
that slaughtered 19 children
um and then the in it was it the nra had
a big convention and this is the one
that he went to where he's going and
screaming was it that one or was it cpac
i don't remember no it wasn't i don't
believe because it would have been
bigger news i don't think it was after
uvalde so this was not the nra one this
was another one
he ran into ted cruz and he ran into it
was in texas right because yeah uh eye
patch eye patch mcca he called them eye
patch mccain yep exactly this is the guy
that was yelling eye patch mccain
at uh jesus his name i'm i'm having a
brain part here now all i can see is the
pirate i can see man dan crenshaw
congressman dan crenshaw he was yelling
eye patch mccain i patched mccain you're
a rhino you're rhino and all this [__]
from a very gerrymandered district too
right right yeah that looks like an ipad
yeah you have not seen if you haven't
yet go look at that district yeah go
just just google dan crenshaw's district
and go to google images you will see his
[__] district even looks like a night
batch it's kind of funny but anyways and
i'm i'm actually not saying that patch
mccain is not a
the wrong name to give dan crenshaw here
yeah but alex stein is the one that was
yelling him and he's the other he's the
one that was calling ted cruz of all
people a globalist right are you i mean
which is as if he he takes flights to
cancun maybe right right right but also
the um
the language that alex stein uses he's
one of these conspiracy theorists he's
big on to the right wing and also he's
like this is all comedy it's it's not
comedy right well he's not a comedian
he's right but when you hear this
globalist language it is code for
anti-semitism right he's an anti-semite
well i mean when you when you go on
tucker carlson's show and you're you're
a guest on all these right-wing [__]
shows like tucker carlson like and some
of these other [__] shows that claim
to be comedy um
podcasts and whatnot you really you
really you really are uh showing that
you are an anti-semite when you say
stuff like globalist especially and it's
really weird for anyone
anyone to call ted cruz of all people a
[__] globalist like if you just take
the word and do the definition i mean
again
a globalist isn't someone who leaves the
country and goes to mexico the cancun to
sit on the beach and sit margaritas just
because your state is under a
snowmageddon i mean that's just called
being an [__] an inconsiderate
selfish [__] right and i might have a
little more respect for alex here if he
would have just called ted cruz an
[__] not a globalist but listen to
what he says listen to the vile [__] and
it really borders on sexual harassment
here i believe um what he says the cat
calls and it's not even really cat calls
because he thinks this is funny you see
him smiling here
and it's it's just a joke tony it's just
a joke
now this is aoc getting out of a secure
vehicle because because of people like
this and marjorie taylor green and
lauren bobert ao we we as taxpayers have
had to spend money
to protect aoc because she is a congress
person because there's threats on her
life and threats like this in public
that's why we have to afford her
security because she is a member of the
government yeah we have to protect those
people when they're under threat
and it's it's because of actual congress
people and a bonehead like this that
they have but let's play the video here
it's not very long you can watch the
vile [__]
um that spews out of his mouth towards
aoc as she walks up the steps of the
capitol see my favorite big booty latina
i love you a.s.c you're my favorite
she wants to kill babies but she's still
beautiful you look very beautiful in
that dress you look very sexy look at
that booty on aoc that's my favorite big
booty latina
now i want to pause it here because
aoc had about enough of this guy at this
point now here's my thing gabe
um aoc
was not she before she was a congress
person she was a very hard-working
blue-collar person yeah she she worked
she was a bartender
she's also dealt with this stuff before
these type of [__] i almost bet aoc
has grabbed one of these little [__]
like this alex by the nape of his nick
and kick and threw him out of a bar
using his head to open a door i'm sure
she's done that oh yeah
100 has done that before but here with
this pop collar of a of a you know a
little like right shirt and he's got his
sperry boats shoes and he's got his
[__]
uh you know
uh little little shorts and he's like
yeah what's going on he's got his
[__] oakley's and [__] like that's
the type of person this [__] [__]
is the guy that would be a complete
dick to someone that was giving them a
drink right ooby dooby puts it perfect
here what a douche canoe oh absolutely
like if he had an official title that's
exactly what it would be yeah but hey
but even 50 shades of wave points let me
finish the video because if it weren't
for her staffer i believe that's who
this is here she probably would have
just beat the holy piss out of this oh
yeah yeah
dude
no no no no no don't don't go beat the
holy hell out of him because she knew
she probably would but let's watch
a little selfie i love it my favorite
aoc nice to meet you look how sexy she
looks in that dress
i love it aoc
here here's the thing here's the thing i
want to point out too aoc is a beautiful
woman she's absolutely a beautiful woman
way way more beautiful than any of these
republican congresswomen like marjorie
to either green or lauren
she's a beautiful woman
and the reason why he's doing this is
because
he is such a [__] scumbag
that he probably he probably
he
and it's kind of weird but he probably
has fantasies about a oh oh yeah yeah
yeah and that's one hundred percent
yeah doing his perverted sexual fantasy
right out here in the open on camera
right talking about her big booty and
all this stuff which uh you know again
aoc is a very beautiful woman not only
she's super smart and she's a great ally
for democracy now you know i don't agree
with her on everything right and that's
the thing i think it's important point
like regardless of what you think of
aoc
right
politics or personality or whatever
having someone do that to you on this
you know the steps of the capital
i think is you know is immature and also
it just it come on man like it's 2022
we're still doing this [__] right the
the good thing is that people like this
are in the minority these [__] incels
these white dudes who feel like they're
entitled to say whatever they want you
know someday it's not gonna play out
well for him
and then he's
and he's gonna play the victim you know
um
whether he gives off he definitely gives
off nick winter's vibes too oh yeah yeah
you know high and mighty when you've got
the camera on you in a place where you
feel secure and safe whether it's in a
in front of a green screen or yelling
things to an elected official who can't
do anything about it
but as soon as the camera's off and
you're in an area that you shouldn't be
in or shouldn't say something
like [__] happens and like
he would 100 cower down in the fetal
position and be like no guys please
don't do that
50 shade says here as a male bartender
who's worked next to women like aoc
i can tell you for a fact that she would
have [__] this dude up
no question no question
she has dealt with [__] and douche
canoes
um and someone put it there
before and knows how to handle and the
other thing too is like what are we you
know this guy's like oh man i got great
content and it's like what are we
accomplishing here like what did you
prove
if anything other than you looking like
a dick
and then all all of the people are like
well it's a joke it's a joke it's funny
it's like well where's the joke
right like what was the joke you were
talking about her physical appearance
i don't know how that's funny but
whatever right well i mean it's kind of
funny how he hates her so much that he
loves her
right
i mean it's clear in the basement of his
parents house when the when the lights
are dim and the screen is bright he's
taking out certain fantasies on himself
you know yeah he's probably got a lot of
aos uh socks with the uh with uh aoc
sharpied on him probably um weird
[__] dude weird [__] guy weird
dude
weird some [__] now speaking of weird
that the title of our show today and
sort of the highlight on twitter this
morning and the distraction from the
right wing from actually what happened
on january 6th
is that ashley babbitt's husband
is saying that she helped trying to stop
the insurrection and stop oh yeah
stop by going through the window i guess
so well that doesn't make any sense the
the problem that her husband has here
and i told him he can [__] off and the
reason why is because i don't know
there's
the thing like video footage
yeah you can see it's like literally on
this scenario right now right exactly
what she tried to do now again this is
put out by the washington post this
clippier
originally i believe it's from
uh
jewish ginger resistor is the account
that i found it on
but this was originally posted by the
washington post here it's just over two
minutes here
let's watch a little bit of the evidence
of why
ashley babbitt was the insurrection not
trying to stop it
now what you're seeing here is law
enforcement standing in front of a
locked door at the capitol during the
january 6 insurrection yeah and they're
going to already have a broken window
here right right
there
it seems like they're really
trying to get people to leave not that i
mean that guy is punching the door next
to the guy's face right because he is so
he's lucky
really
you know a lot of these people remind me
especially the guy who was like punching
is when you see videos or maybe you see
some kid on the playground who's like
they're really upset right and they
cannot express how they feel with words
right they are not able to say like i'm
upset because this you know
instead they take it out physically and
they start throwing [__] and having a
tantrum very much like trump in the in
the backseat of the suv right you know
so in this scenario it's very much the
same thing like you look at this person
this guy uh this [__] alpha male
is not able to express themselves
verbally
in a coherent
and understandable you know kind of
fashion so he has to take it out
physically and he has to punch the door
and glass next to this guy's face who's
just doing his job right defending the
back of the blue
no no no well let's punch the blue
that's what i'm saying speaking of
listen to what they say in this in this
tape here
now you notice that they point out here
that this is the speaker's lobby so this
is the hallway where the speakers lobby
is not just the democratic speaker this
is any speaker republican democrat so
keep that in mind
[Music]
now here you see they point out that
this
person with the
what appears to be an american flag on
her backpack um
this is ashley babbitt here the the the
actual ashley babbitt that her husband
said she was trying to stop the
insurrection which clearly here you'll
see that she was not trying to stop it
she was actually encouraging it let's
watch
now here's a guy in this i don't know
what kind of hand you call this it's
kind of a weird hit he's got that's the
guy that i feel like was just he was
just pounding the glass a moment ago now
he he actually comes in here and says
hey hey hey let these guys do the job
the reason why this gets to this point
is because there's a tactical team on
their way up to this door so what has
happened and i believe this evidence
will bear out is that
and i think it was in the case of the
the police officer who's on the other
side of the door who had to shoot ashley
babbitt because she was trying to break
through the locked restricted area
um
he said there there's a tactical team on
their way up to protect this door and
the reason why is because these caps
weren't
weren't in its position to protect this
door so there's a tactical team which
we'll see at the end here but watch
[Music]
[__] the blue i mean they turned on that
back to blue [__] really fast yeah let's
watch
he wants you to go home i'm recording
and there's so many people it's just
they're going to push their way up here
bro i see people out there get hurt i
don't want to see you get hurt i just we
will make
we won't make a path dead ass like we
don't
it really looks like ashley babbitt over
here is this a proud boys shirt
uh which one this guy is wearing this
black shirt with the no no no no in
front of it with the backpack he's got
right here black shirt with the yellow
the guy that was he was wearing i had a
moment with the flurry hat yeah i don't
know he might be a problem it looks like
a proud boy polo but i don't know you
see what looks like ashley babbitt
standing over here definitely trying to
fend off all the protesters and the
insurrections
and the the people who are being
traitors against look at that guy's face
on the right here man these people are
[__] nuts freaking out let's so let's
watch what happens as ashley babbitt
doesn't try to stop the insurrectionist
from moving through this restricted area
in fact she actually is the first one
that tries to breach it
now
you watch the cops walk away from the
door here's the reason why the cops walk
away from the door is because a tactical
team is coming up the stairs to take
their positions yeah um i believe that
these caps probably were dare looked a
little bit in their duty as they should
have maintained their post until the
tactical team was there but i'm sure
they were terrified that these people
were going to do something but let's
watch
are these are really nice tourists
and you notice here that ashley babbitt
is not trying to prevent these people
from breaking through this restricted
door
she's not doing that ashley babbitt's
husband whatever the [__] your name is
she's not doing that in the evidence
here let's keep going
there's the gun there's the gun what the
[__] do you think would happen
so
people he this this person that's behind
this camera is trying to warn people
that there is an officer behind this
locked restricted area that they have
piled stuff in front of yeah
willing to defend it because it is a
very highly restricted area
and it is locked and they have
restricted it and they are going to
defend it because there are people
behind there that are our government
that need to be defended watch as the
person that ashley babbitt's husband
claims she was trying to stop the people
from going through
watch what she does
[Music]
here you see two different angles one
angle is the the gun
the other angle is from a different
camera and you'll see over here on the
side the window that someone tries to
breach
there she is climbing into the window
okay now i'm gonna fast forward through
this part here
um
what happens is the officer shoots her
as she goes through the window because
there's a restricted locked area and
there they are going to defend it now
here's the thing she's laying on the
floor here i want you to pay attention
to who comes up the stairs immediately
after
you see the tactical team here moving up
the stairs that were moving into place
to defend this to defend this door
um now
i don't know what ashley babbitt's
husband has watched or the evidence that
he's watched but this here clearly shows
that ashley babbitt up until the very
last moment where she was trying to
overthrow our government where she was a
traitor to her constitution because this
person has taken a note to the military
okay
up to the very last moment
up to the very last moment of her being
shot
she was she was not
trying to stop it she was doing the
exact opposite yeah she was inciting it
and she was
she was the insurrection that's why she
died that day because she got
brainwashed into believing trump's
[__] and she became part of the
insurrection and she was the
insurrection regardless of what [__]
lies you want to spread and all the
nonsense and all the [__]
she was the insurrection
she's the perfect picture of it and
she's the reason why
she's the re and really honestly i
believe that ashley babbitt being shot
in this moment is what saved a lot of
these people's lives standing there
yes they were all delusional about how
how serious these officers were about
defending that restricted area
these people really boarded on getting
themselves killed
a lot more than just the one of ashley
babbitt
going into restricted areas and and
thinking that
our government wouldn't be defended from
them from overturning it and being
traitors to our country to believe that
our [__] country wouldn't defend our
government wouldn't defend our democracy
was really [__] boneheaded now
we see in the hearings
the january 6 hearings that more and
more republicans were working as hard as
they possibly could
to undermine yeah the defense of our
democracy and i believe more and more
and that's going to come out and i want
to bring that up here
gabe next week thursday is supposed to
be the final hearing in this series is
what people are saying
so it feels like to us um because we
don't have any really
insider information
other than what we've been hearing from
the hill
that there is going to be maybe another
series after they come back from recess
so more hearings based on more evidence
that they collect right but right now
next thursday is going to be the final
eighth hearing
in this series um and we're we've gotten
an insight to what the hearing is going
to be about liz cheney kind of previewed
it for us at the very end of the last
hearing
but we don't know what time
yeah
it's gonna it's supposed to be a prime
time so you know if we look back at what
the last one was we're talking
what was it uh
five yeah well it's hard well five p.m
pacific yeah so eight eight yeah i think
that's what it was yeah so so it's
probably in the same time frame as that
but they've moved these time frames all
around and even days before and they
can't are they prospects i would imagine
they would probably still go with a
similar time right because you gotta you
you start with the prime time and you
you right out of the gate you establish
that
all of these people thought trump was a
[__] idiot and then he shouldn't be
doing what he's doing right ivanka bill
barr you know jared kushner all of these
people they threw those out in the even
the first half because they knew people
probably weren't going to watch the
whole thing and they needed to make sure
that they got the actual sound bites
that people would start sharing and then
people like wait what the [__] going
on and then go watch if they weren't
watching and i think for this one we're
gonna focus now on yes the 187 minutes
of just like what was going on with
trump
but you want to end it right if you're
going to start with saying that he that
he was delusional and that we told him
not to do it but he still pursued it
anyway and then the next hearings we lay
out all the facts of like here are the
things that happened where we
specifically told him he was wrong it
was [__] it wasn't real he shouldn't
be pursuing this he should move on
and now we're gonna focus on the like
you know the
the the the cream of the crop type of
evidence here which will probably learn
who the the witnesses that he was
tampering with will get their testimony
and or depositions
and then we'll find out exactly what
trump was doing and i think it's going
to be of like you know a real
one-two punch
and then probably in the next series of
hearings they might you know they might
pile on with like you were saying like
you know we know at least two
congressional two people right ron
johnson and andy biggs that we're trying
to directly influence the outcome of the
election by doing fake elector uh um
electors so we might find more of that
as more people come forward there you
know more than information might be
revealed in the second series of
hearings but that could be
kind of going after the other people
right if this one is focused on trump
the next one as we come closer to the
midterms so it's like season one season
two right you're like
yeah you're like here's the villain and
here's everything that happened
now we're gonna do a whole story
character arc for all of these other
people sitting in congress and i
wouldn't be surprised if they were doing
that as a second series to say this
person and this person and this person
and this person were all directly
involved and those people are running
for re-election
in the midterm right and target them
that way well here's what i want to tell
the audience make sure to stay tuned for
the finale of season one right the
insurrection hearings uh the january 6th
select committee is going to reconvene
thursday we are assuming that it's 8
eastern it's just an assumption we'd
have no confirmation of that and that's
why we don't have a link over on the
midas touch network yet on their youtube
channel as soon as we can get some sort
of confirmation we will make that link
for you guys to go ahead and set your
reminder for that hearing but just know
that these hearings have been fluid
meaning they have changed on the fly so
thursday is what it's set for we are not
confirming the time we believe that
it'll be about 8 p.m eastern is what we
believe so we will start an hour early
though whatever time it is here on the
midas touch network so go follow the
minus touch network on their on their
youtube midas touch go follow that
youtube it will be on there
make sure to set your reminder when that
link comes now also follow us on youtube
don't forget to follow the tony michaels
podcast if you're here and also download
every single episode of the tony
michaels podcast we are here every
single weekday monday through friday
two hours youtube twitter twitch and we
simulcast from the minus touch facebook
page but you can download our show seven
days a week gabe seven days a week
because tomorrow is friday we have bone
end of the week tomorrow we're gonna
have the bone of the week poll tonight
so go follow us on twitter at tony
michael's pod you will be able to vote
for bone end of the week there we will
break it down tomorrow in the second
hour and then sunday we'll replay
bonehead of the week you can download it
play it on youtube and then we'll have a
best of the week
which my guess is we'll probably pull
from the last hearing for the best of
the week that is some of the best
footage that we have uh from the week so
go follow us all those places make sure
to look be on the lookout for that link
at the midas touch network
for that hearing day eight
the last in this series of hearings next
thursday we are assuming the time will
be 8 eastern we have not confirmed that
yet as soon as we can get some sort of
confirmation we will definitely
definitely
get you that link until tomorrow don't
forget bone end of the week vote youtube
or twitter
until tomorrow everyone surfs up
[__]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
[Music]
murphy's meal barn had asked